we are joined from Middlesboro by the
shadow transport secretary and a
McDonald
thank you very much for being on the
show today mr. McDonald we heard from
Stephen Barclay a little earlier the
Bret's at secretary who says he thinks
there is a landing zone for a brexit
deal is that something you welcome well
I don't know what that is because we are
told that negotiations are under way and
conversations are being had but we heard
from amber rod that the effort is
focused on crashing out with no deal and
Leah vodka and others in the European
Union are saying that they are aware of
no proposition from the UK government so
if you'd like to tell us what that
landing zone is at the moment the
landing zone that we do know about is
describing the yellow hammer documents
which is a complete havoc across our
country so we need we need to know what
it is he's talking about we would know
of course that the Labour Party wants to
avoid a no deal brexit if the government
does bring back a deal is there any
chance that Labour might actually
support it well I have to see what the
what the deal is but if at the moment
Boris Johnson is telling us that he is
not going to ask for an extension and it
seems that all of his energy is about
delivering a No Deal crash out and
that's the thing that we've got to focus
on and to make sure that doesn't happen
and we say let's get that extension
according to law and we've got no
confidence he'll abide by the law and
that once we have that let's have that
general election and we'll have a
referendum our promise we'll do we have
a referendum in that where the people
decide on the future relationship with
the European Union that seems to me the
most pragmatic way to go about this
issue and of course that's Jeremy Corbyn
giving that lead trying to hold the
entire country together with the only
party trying to unite the country and
address the real issues that they're
facing on the daily basis rather than
having splitting one way or the other
labour of course voted against an
election when that was put to Parliament
so when do you want the election to be
I I want this to have that election when
we've got this whole issue of the crash
out nailed down and absolutely beyond
doubt that we will not be crashing out
without a deal on the 31st of October
and we don't know that yet
well after we've got it absolutely clear
if it would be it would be beyond doubt
the the moment that Boris Johnson writes
that letter and makes that request as he
is bound to do according to law the
active Parliament that was passed LED
that out in the appendix and he simply
has to attach his signature to that
letter and if he does that then we're in
the business of moving on to a general
election and what if he doesn't because
what he's saying in a minute is that no
matter what happens he's going to take
the UK out of the EU by the 31st of
October yeah well there's already a
petition to the the court of sessions
and I think people are looking at the
alternative ways to progress that it
would be an absolute parlor state of
affairs if the Prime Minister the United
Kingdom decided that he wouldn't abide
by the law of the land we would be into
a a bind constitutionally if that was
the case and we'd have to have the
ability to override that to make sure
that the Prime Minister could not just
simply ignore and disobey the law of the
land now I know that there's a disregard
for our judges and that worries me
greatly because we must always uphold
the rule of law and the Independence of
the judiciary but I strongly suspect
that that will be one of the options for
the judiciary to enter into the fray and
we'll have that decision made in any
event there may be other techniques as
well perhaps others signing that letter
other than Boris Johnson so you can
satisfy himself that he hasn't asked for
the extension but it's been requested in
any event and the European Union have
granted it so there's many a twist here
Sophie between now and the 31st of
October it does feel that whatever
happens a general election is going to
happen sooner rather than later in that
election people are going to want to
know
exactly what the Labour Party stands for
so members of javac Shadow Cabinet and
said she plan to renegotiate a deal and
then put that deal back to the people in
a second referendum so in that
referendum would you campaign to leave
or to remain my purse of you I would do
again what I did last time I would
campaign to remain I would vote to
remain
I just came away from a meeting in my
locality with the chemicals and process
industry and I heard Steve Bartley
talking about the continued investment
in in UK industry I've got to tell him
that the there are really worrying signs
that the these businesses are poised to
take their businesses elsewhere if they
are facing tariffs of raw materials in
and finished products out and delays
their systems if those tanks drop
they'll talk about shutdowns their
multinational companies they will just
relocate where they don't have to have
those problems and we know from our car
factories that they're looking to build
future lines elsewhere Nissan have made
their own announcements so the effects
will be catastrophic so it's absolutely
imperative that we do stop that and
that's what I'm saying that my region in
particular will be one of the hardest
hit by a disruption from the European
Union and it'd be jobs and as as ever
people like Boris Johnson Jacob Riis MOG
when they smashed the ship against the
rocks they'll have the lifeboat it's the
working class who will not they're the
ones who'll pay for it with their jobs
and their prosperity and and that's
these deceit that Boris Johnson's tried
to perpetrate upon the British people at
the moment and we've got to expose that
further for the deceit that it truly is
I'm just trying to get my head around
what you said at the beginning of that
answer which is that the position is
that you would try and renegotiate a
deal and then you say that you would
then campaign to remain against the deal
that you just negotiated I mean why
would the EU do anything to try and
negotiate a deal if you're saying you
just got a week's worth it
no not think about it you know if we put
in this back to
to the people for them to make the
decision the option of leaving is
available to them it makes absolute
sense to get the best possible deal that
will be the least disruptive to our
economy but what's interesting it's a
new hang on it because it's in their
interest to no no no listen it's just if
you if you've got the option to remain
that's that's a straightforward we know
what that means if we've got a credible
deal it means that we're trying to
mitigate and minimize the impact of
leaving the European Union the European
Union would want that so should the UK
we should not be rushing headlong into a
disruption from the EU and then suddenly
threw ourselves into the arms of Donald
Trump with all of the consequences of a
trade deal that's got a totally no flee
favor the USA when we have our
conversations with European Union this
isn't about the football match or who
wins who loses this is about working
with our partners to find the best
possible relationship going forward I'm
of the view and I've always been of the
view that remaining in the European
Union is that better option but we will
put it back to the British people and if
they decide to leave then of course it
should be on terms that are going to
protect our jobs protect our economy the
environment consumer rights and the
whole range of issues that we are so
concerned about that makes absolute
sense and it's a way of holding the
entire nation together and that's the
path that we're going to follow